MORE.
HE SHARED HIS PLANS THROUGH THE
NEW YEAR.
HERE IS PART 1 OF EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
MR. PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US TONIGHT.
>> President Trump: THANK YOU,
LAURA.
>> Laura: TONIGHT MIKE POMPEO
GAVE A FORCEFUL PRESS CONFERENCE
THE FALLOUT FROM THE IRANIAN
JETLINER GOING DOWN.
HIS CONCERN IS THAT PEOPLE
AREN'T UNDERSTANDING THE EMINENT
NATURE OF THE THREAT OF
SOLEIMANI.
HE WAS PRESSED ON THAT TODAY.
HE SAID THERE WERE LARGE SCALE
ATTACKS PLANNED ON U.S.
FACILITIES.
BUT HE DIDN'T GO MORE SPECIFIC.
DON'T THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT SPECIFICALLY
WAS TARGETED WITHOUT REVEALING
MASSES AND SOURCES AND SOURCES?
>> President Trump: I DON'T
THINK SO BUT WE WILL TELL YOU
PROBABLY IT WOULD BE THE EMBASSY
IN BAGHDADI AND USE ALL THAT
WITH ALL OF THE MEN, VERY FEW
MEANT WOMEN CIRCLING IN AND
CIRCLING IN.
VERY STRONGLY, VERY VICIOUSLY
KNOCKING OUT WINDOWS AND TRYING
TO GET INTO.
THEY WERE CLOSE TO GETTING INTO.
I CALLED OUT TO MILITARY.
THEY SAID THEY WILL HAVE IT
THERE TOMORROW.
I SAID NOPE, YOU WILL HAVE IT
THERE TODAY BECAUSE WE WILL NOT
HAVE ANOTHER BENGHAZI ON HER
HANDS.
WE DID AN AMAZING JOB.
WE NEVER GET CREDIT FOR
ANYTHING.
THAT'S OKAY.
WE ARE THE GREATEST ECONOMY WE
HAVE EVER HAD.
BUT I THINK HE WOULD HAVE HAD
ANOTHER BEEN BECAUSE HE HAD WE
NOT ACTED QUICKLY.
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN STOPPED.
THIS WAS STOPPED.
AND WE HAD APACHES GOING THERE,
THE HELICOPTERS AND THEY WERE
DROPPING PLAYERS ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
A LOT OF THINGS WERE HAPPENING.
AND EVERYBODY DISAPPEARED.
>> Laura: DID THEY HAVE LARGE
SCALED ATTACKS FOR OTHER
EMBASSIES AND IF THOSE WERE
PLANNED, WHY CAN'T WE REBUILD
THAT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WOULDN'T THAT HELP YOUR CASE?
>> President Trump: I CAN
REVEAL THAT I THINK IT WAS FOUR
EMBASSIES.
I THINK BAGHDAD ALREADY STARTED.
THEY WERE REALLY AMAZED THAT WE
CAME IN WITH THAT KIND OF FORCE.
WE CAME IN WITH A VERY POWERFUL
FORCE.
THAT ENDED ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
BUT BAGHDAD CERTAINLY WOULD HAVE
BEEN THE LEAD, BUT I THINK IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN FOUR MILITARY
BASES.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS TOO.
IT WAS IMMINENT.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, HE WAS GONE.
>> Laura: WHY IS NANCY PELOSI
DESCRIBING HER BRIEFING AS
DISMISSIVE AND DISDAINFUL DON'T
MAKE DISDAINFUL?
MICHAEL HE IT WAS INSULTING.
WHAT WAS SAID TO MOLLIFY THE
CONCERNS OF YOUR STRONGEST
SUPPORTERS LIKE MIKE LEE?
>> President Trump: HE IS A
GREAT SUPPORTER AND A FRIEND
THAT CALLED ME A LITTLE WHILE
AGO.
HE SAID I WANTED TO GET MORE
INFORMATION.
LOOK, AND HAVE ALSO HAD CALLS
FROM THE SENATORS, CONGRESSMEN
WHO SAID HE WAS THE SINGLE BEST
BRIEFING.
ONE PERSON SAID THEY HAD BEEN
THERE TEN YEARS.
THE SINGLE BEST BRIEFING THEY
HAVE EVER HAD.
ONE SAID, 20 YEARS, THE SINGLE
BEST MILITARY BRIEFING THEY HAVE
EVER HAD.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT MIKE HAD TO
COME ON MIKE WANTED CERTAIN
THINGS SAID AND WE JUST COULDN'T
SAY THEM BUT MAYBE WE COULD SAY
INDIVIDUALLY TO HIM AND
CERTAINLY A TRUSTWORTHY PERSON.
>> Laura: ARE YOU WORRIED THE
DEMOCRATS CAN'T BE TRUSTED WITH
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION?
THAT IS WHAT IT SOUND LIKE WHEN
MIKE PENCE GAVE THE MESSAGE THE
OTHER DAY.
>> President Trump: I AM
CERTAIN THERE CERTAINLY WORRIED
ABOUT IT.
CAN YOU IMAGINE COME A SPLIT
SECOND TIMING, EXECUTED LIKE
NOBODY HAS SEEN IN MANY, MANY YA
NOBODY HAS SEEN IN MANY, MANY YS
NOBODY HAS SEEN IN MANY, MANY YO
NOBODY HAS SEEN IN MANY, MANY YN
NOBODY HAS SEEN IN MANY, MANY YS
NOBODY HAS SEEN IN MANY, MANY YL
NOBODY HAS SEEN IN MANY, MANY YI
NOBODY HAS SEEN IN MANY, MANY YA
NOBODY HAS SEEN IN MANY, MANY Y.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THEY WANT US TO
COME UP AND SPEAK TO CROOKED,
CORRUPT POLITICIAN ADAM SCHIFF?
OH, ADAM, WE HAVE SOMEBODY WE
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET FOR A
LONG TIME.
WE HAVE A SHOT AT HIM RIGHT NOW.
CAN WE MEET TO GET YOUR
APPROVAL, ADAM SCHIFF?
WELL, LET'S DO IT IN A COUPLE OF
DAYS.
OH, OKAY, IT DOESN'T WORK THAT
WAY.
NUMBER ONE, NUMBER TWO, THEY
LEAK.
ANYTHING WE GIVE WILL BE LEAKED
IMMEDIATELY.
YOU WILL SAY BREAKING NEWS AND
WE ARE ABOUT TO BE ATTACKED IN
25 MINUTES.
BY THE WAY, I'M NOT SOMEBODY
THAT WANTS TO ATTACK.
I PROBABLY COULD HAVE ATTACKED
FIVE TIMES, TEN TIMES HAVING TO
DO WITH IRAN.
I HAVE BEEN VERY GUARDED BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
BUT WE MAY HAVE TO DO SOMETHING.
WE HAVE TO BE IN A POSITION
WHERE WE CAN DO IT EVEN FROM THE
NEGOTIATING STANDPOINT.
BUT HOPEFULLY, IT WON'T BE
NECESSARY.
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS SANCTIONS.
THEY ARE DOING POORLY.
THEY HAVE RIOTS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
I THINK IT STRAIGHTENED OUT
EASY, BUT IT'S UP TO THEM.
>> Laura: SPEAKING OF
SANCTIONS ILHAN OMAR SAID TODAY
THAT THIS IS AKIN TO ECONOMIC
WARFARE AGAINST IRAN COME EVEN
THOUGH SHE SUPPORTS SANCTIONS
AGAINST ISRAEL.
>> President Trump: YEAH.
SHE HATES ISRAEL.
SHE HATES JEWISH PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT HER
RED BRICK.
IT IS INCREDIBLE WHAT HAS
HAPPENED TO THE DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESS.
THEY USED TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF
ISRAEL.
TODAY, THEY ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
HER AND AOC, RASHIDA TLAIB, THEY
KNOW NOTHING.
A POOR STUDENT COME UP FOR
EVERYTHING AND SHE COMES AND
TALKS ABOUT THE GREEN NEW DEAL
AND ALL OF THESE, WONDERFUL, BUT
YOU KNOW, AS I SAID LAST NIGHT,
I DON'T LIKE TALKING ABOUT THE
GREEN NEW DEAL.
IT IS TOO EARLY.
I WANT TO SAY BUT TWO WEEKS
BEFORE BECAUSE THEY MAY CHANGE
THEIR MIND.
>> Laura: BERNIE SANDERS IS
OUT BUT YOU'RE NOT SURPRISED TO
DISCUSS IRAN ON WHAT HAPPENED.
HE BASICALLY SAID THIS.
>> JUST AS WE WERE LED INTO
VIETNAM BY LIES BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS MISLEADING US
ON IRAN.
A FASCINATION OF QASSEM
SOLEIMANI.
BY CLAIMING HE WAS PLANNING
EMINENT ATTACKS.
THEY PRODUCE NO EVIDENCE THAT
NOT EVEN A CLASSIFIED SETTING.
>> President Trump: I DON'T
SEE IT HAPPENING.
WE ARE THERE FOR A VERY, VERY
STRONG REASON.
THEY CANNOT HAVE NUCLEAR WEAPON
WEAPONS.
THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL SIGNED BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA GAVE
$150 BILLION AND THAT IS WHEN
THE REAL TERRORIST STARTED.
THEY TOOK THE MONEY AND USED IT
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
YOU LOOK AT YEMEN AND ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE HAPPENING
INCLUDING SYRIA, THEY WERE USING
$1.8 BILLION IN CASH FROM A
$1.71.8 BILLION IN CASH, GREEN,
BEAUTIFUL CASH.
AND HOW DID THEY HAVE THE POWER
TO DO THIS?
LOADS OF CASH.
INSTEAD OF IRAN SAYING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, THAT IS NICE AND
LET'S GET ALONG, DO WELL, LET'S
BUILD BUILDINGS AND IRAN, THEY
SAID DEATH TO AMERICA.
THEY SAID IT WHEN THEY WERE
SIGNING.
WHEN JOHN KERRY SIGNED, AND BY
THE WAY HE VIOLATED THE ACT.
>> Laura: HE IS OUT THERE
SLAMMING YOU.
>> President Trump: THIS GUY
VIOLATED THE LOGAN ACT WITH HIS
CONVERSATIONS COME OKAY.
BUT WHEN JOHN KERRY WAS OUT
THERE MAKING THE DEAL, AND THEY
HAVE PEOPLE SCREAMING DEATH TO
AMERICA, DEATH TO AMERICA.
WHO SIGNS A DEAL WHILE THEY
SCREAM DEATH TO AMERICA?
>> Laura: HE SAID HE STABILIZE
THE MIDDLE EAST AFTER
CAMPAIGNING A MAN OF RESTRAINT,
NOT INTERVENTIONALLISM.
JOHN KERRY SANG THIS AND ALL THE
OBAMA FOLKS, SUSAN RICE, THEY
ARE KIND OF WAITING IN THE
WINGS, SEE, HE IS THE GUY THAT
WE TOLD YOU HE WAS.
>> President Trump: IF YOU
LOOK AT THE MIDDLE EAST RIGHT
NOW, IT IS MUCH CALMER THAN WHEN
I GOT HERE.
WHEN I GOT HERE, IT WAS ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
NUMBER ONE WE GOT RID OF THE
CALIPHATE, THE ISIS CALIPHATE.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PRISONERS
AND WE KILLED MOST OF THEIR
FIGHTERS.
WE'VE GOTTEN RID OF VICES.
THEY COME BACK AND TAKE CARE OF
IT.
OTHER PEOPLE SHOULD TAKE CARE OF
OTHER COUNTRIES SHOULD HAVE
TAKEN CARE OF IT, EUROPE SHOULD
TAKE THEM BACK.
>> Laura: AND ADEL STEPPED UP
AND I KNOW THEY COMMITTED TO
DOING MORE IN THE MIDDLE EAST, U
DOING MORE IN THE MIDDLE EAST, T
WHAT EXTENT MIKE
SPECIFICALLY WILL NATO
CONTRIBUTE TO TAKE THE BURDEN
OFF THE AMERICAN TAXPAYERS.
>> AS I CAME IN NATO WAS
VIRTUALLY A DEAD ORGANIZATION.
IT HAD NO MONEY, NOBODY WAS
PAYING EXCEPT US.
PRACTICALLY NOBODY WAS PAYING.
IF YOU LOOK AT H HURT OF MONEY
AND FUNDS RECEIVED, IT LOOKED
LIKE A ROLLER COASTER DOWN.
NOW SECRETARY COME I THINK HE IS
TERRIFIC AND MY FIRST YEAR, I
RAISED $130 BILLION FROM THEM,
NOT FROM US.
AND NOW HE ANNOUNCED
$530 BILLION ALL BECAUSE OF ME.
HE'S MY BIGGEST SALESMAN, MY
GREATEST SALESMAN, THE
SECRETARY.
BUT LOOK, YOU ARE THERE FOR
RUSSIA AND EUROPE, OKAY?
BY THE WAY IT WAS MUCH MORE FOR
EUROPE THAN US.
>> Laura: WHY ARE WE
PROTECTING THEM?
ALL THE MONEY SENDING TO NATO,
WHAT ARE WE PROTECTING THEM
FROM?
>> President Trump: THEY BUILT
AN OFFICE BUILDING $3 BILLION.
THEY DO LOTS OF THINGS THEY
SHOULDN'T BE DOING BEFORE I GOT
HERE.
BUT I RAISED A LOT OF MONEY.
WE CAN USE NATO AND A NUMBER OF
LOCATIONS.
WE CAN USE NATO AS AN EXAMPLE IN
THE MIDDLE EAST.
THAT IS WHAT WE SHOULD DO.
FRANKLY, MORE PALATABLE TO
COUNTRIES AND INTERNATIONAL
FORCE COMES IN RATHER THAN THE
UNITED STATES.
FROM OUR STANDPOINT, LET
SOMEBODY ELSE PAY FOR IT.
WHY ARE WE ALWAYS PAYING?
WE PAY FOR EVERYTHING.
ONE THING, I MOVED THE TROOPS ON
THE BORDER BETWEEN TURKEY AND
SYRIA.
THAT TURNED OUT TO BE SUCH A
SUCCESSFUL MOVE.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED.
NOW THEY PROTECT -- THEY BEEN
FIGHTING OVER THE BORDER FOR
1,000 YEARS.
WHY SHOULD WE DO IT?
THEN THEY SAY HE LEFT TROOPS IN
SYRIA.
YOU KNOW WHAT I DID?
I LEFT TROOPS TO TAKE THE OIL.
THE ONLY TROOPS I HAVE ARE
TAKING THE OIL.
THEY ARE PROTECTING THE OIL.
>> Laura: WE ARE TAKING THE
OIL.
>> President Trump: MAYBE WE
WILL, MAYBE WE WON'T.
PARENTS
WHEN THEY ARE PROTECTING THE
FACILITY.
>> President Trump:
UNITED STATES HAS THE OIL.
SO THEY SAY HE LEFT TROOPS IN
SYRIA.
NO, WE ARE PROTECTING THE OIL.
WE HAVE THE OIL.
>> Laura:
WE Laura:
WE Haura:
WE HAVra:
WE HAVE :
>> Laura:
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" REPORTING
AFTER THE STRIKE, MR. TRUMP TOLD
ASSOCIATES HE WAS UNDER PRESSURE
WITH THE DEAL WITH
GENERAL SOLEIMANI TO TAKE HIM
OUT FROM G.O.P. SENATORS HE USED
AS IMPORTANT SUPPORTERS IN THE
UPCOMING IMPEACHMENT SENATE.
THE ASSOCIATE SAID.
SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVE A LEAK FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE OR SOMEONE.
>> President Trump: THEY JUST
MADE IT UP, IT IS FAKE NEWS.
THEY ARE JUST MAKING IT UP.
THEY ARE ALL VERY DISHONEST,
MOST OF THEM ARE VERY DISHONEST
COMMITTEE PRESENT OR DISHONEST.
I MEAN REALLY DISHONEST.
THEY MADE THAT STORY UP.
>> Laura: SO NO SHIRK ABOUT
LINDSEY GRAHAM?
>> President Trump: ABSOLUTELY
NOT AT ALL.
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS SUPPORT.
LISTEN, AND THE HOUSE WE OWE
196-0 AND THREE DEMOCRATS SO IT
WAS BIPARTISAN I GUESS YOU
COULD SAY.
WE HAVE NOTHING, THEY HAD
NOTHING.
WE DID NOT LOSE ONE REPUBLICAN
VOTE.
AS YOU KNOW, THAT IS UNUSUAL.
IN THE SENATE, I HAVE THE SAME
IF NOT MORE SUPPORT.
I DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT.
I WOULD NEVER COMPROMISE WHAT WE
ARE DOING WITH WITH IRAN AND
POTENTIAL WORD.
ALL THE THINGS.
>> Laura: WE ARE NOT DOING
BUSH 2.0.
THIS IS NOT BUSH 2.0 OR WNV.
>> President Trump: I DON'T
WANT PEOPLE HAVING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS BECAUSE THEY WILL USE
THEM.
I DON'T WANT PEOPLE HAVING
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THAT IS MY BIGGEST THING.
>> Laura: JOHN KERRY WAS OUT
THERE YESTERDAY SANG WELL, YOU
GOT OUT OF THE IRAN DEAL AND
THAT'S WHAT GOT ALL THIS
ATTENTION.
>> President Trump: I DID A
GREAT THING DIDN'T GETTING OUT
OF THE IRAN DEAL.
THEY GAVE $1.8 MILLION TO GET
THAT.
YOU CANNOT DO INSPECTIONS AT THE
MOST IMPORTANT LOCATIONS.
YOU KNOW ANOTHER BIG THING?
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO DO
BALLISTIC MISSILES.
WE COULDN'T GO INTO AREAS AND
LOOK, WE HAVE TO GIVE MASSIVE
NOTICES SO IF THEY WERE DOING
SOMETHING THEY COULD CLEAN THEM
UP.
IT WAS RIDICULOUS.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, IT
EXPIRES.
THIS IS A SHORT-TERM AGREEMENT.
NOW, ONCE IT EXPIRED, THEY HAVE
NUCLEAR PATH AT NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
UNSTOPPED.
IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME, THE
DEAL THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA MADE
WITH JOHN KERRY WHO MAY BE THE
WORST NEGOTIATOR I HAVE EVER
SEEN.
THAT DEAL EXPIRES.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
ONCE IT EXPIRES, YOU CAN'T DO
WHAT I DID.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A DEAL THAT
SAYS ONCE IT EXPIRES, THEY CAN
DO WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
YOU CANNOT LET IRAN HAVE A
NUCLEAR WEAPON.
THAT IS WHAT I'M DOING.
>> Laura: PETE BUTTIGIEG AND
OTHER DEMOCRATS MIGHT PREDICT AT
THIS WHEN I TALK TO MIKE POMPEO
YESTERDAY, ARE ACTUALLY BLAMING
YOUR MOVE AGAINST IRAN FOR THE
DOWNING OF THAT COMMERCIAL
JETLINER AND IRAN AND TEHRAN THE
NIGHT OF THE STRIKES TO FIRE ON
THE ROCKET FACILITIES.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT CHARGE.
>> President Trump: A COUPLE
OF PEOPLE STARTED THAT AND I GOT
IT REAL FAST BY A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PEOPLE, NOT ME.
I THINK IT IS LOWLIFE.
LOOK, HE'S NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
HE WAS A LOUSY MAYOR A PLACE NOT
DOING WELL.
INDIANA IS DOING BELIEVABLY
WELL.
IN THE END OF THE BEST YEAR OF
THEY HAVE EVER HAD TO COME I
THINK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUT BADLY RUN OUT WHAT IS GOING
ON.
SHE IS ANOTHER BEAUTY, LOOK AT
HER PAST, >> Laura: THE IRAQ
HE PRIME MINISTER HAS NOTIFIED
MIKE POMPEO ABOUT POTENTIAL
PLANS DRAWING UP PLANS FOR U.S.
TROOP WITHDRAWAL FROM IRAQ.
MACK.
YOU RAN ON PULLING OUT OF THE
MIDDLE EAST BUT WHY NOT USE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY WE ARE DONE.
>> President Trump: I'M OKAY
WITH IT, BY THE WAY --
>> Laura: YOU ARE OKAY MOOT
REMOVING TROOPS FROM IRAQ?
>> President Trump: THAT IS
WHAT THEY SAY PUBLICLY NOT
PRIVATELY.
IF WE LEAVE, THAT MEANS --
>> Laura: WHY NOT LEAVE?
>> President Trump: I'M NOT SO
BAD WITH IT.
WHEN I HEARD THAT, I SAID TO
COME I HAVEN'T 5,000 TROOPS.
WE HAVE MANY TROOPS IN IRAQ AND
IN TRAINING.
WE TRAINED THEM, BUT IF THEY
WANT US TO LEAD, THEY SPEAK
DIFFERENT PUBLICLY THAN THEY DO
PRIVATELY.
>> Laura: ARE WE SENDING MORE
TROOPS TO THE REGION?
>> President Trump: WE ARE
SENDING MORE TO SAUDI ARABIA AND
SAUDI ARABIA IS PAYING US FOR
IT.
WE ARE DOING SOMETHING NOBODY'S
EVER DONE.
I SAID TO SAUDI ARABIA, WE HAVE
A GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH
SAUDI ARABIA.
LISTEN YOU ARE A RICH COUNTRY.
YOU WANT MORE TROOPS COME I WILL
SEND THEM TO YOU BUT YOU HAVE TO
PAY US.
THEY WERE PAYING US.
THEY HAVE DEPOSITED $1 BILLION
IN THE BANK.
WE ARE GOING TO HELP THEM, BUT
THESE RICH COUNTRIES HAVE TO PAY
FOR IT.
AND 5 MILLION TABLET --
$500 MILLION, THEY GAVE US $500I
$500 MILLION, THEY GAVE US $500L
$500 MILLION, THEY GAVE US $500O
$500 MILLION, THEY GAVE US $500.
I SAID YOU HAVE TO HELP US
ALONG.
WE HAVE 32,000 SOLDIERS IN
SOUTH KOREA PROTECTING YOU FROM
NORTH KOREA.
YOU'VE GOT TO PAY.
THEY GAVE US $500 MILLION.
I MEAN, YOU SAW THAT
BREAKING NEWS BECAUSE NOBODY
WANTS TO REPORT THAT STUFF.
I'M NOT SURE ANYBODY KNOWS IT.
I MIGHT SORT OF THING SAYING
THAT YOU HAVE SOME -- IT'S GOOD
STUFF.
BUT THE WEALTH OF THE COUNTRY.
THEY BUILD ALL YOUR TELEVISION
SETS.
THEY BUILD THE SHIPS, THEY BUILD
A LOT OF THINGS.
WE ARE PROTECTING YOU, YOU HAVE
TO PAY.
THEY PAID US 500 MILLION AND
THEY WILL PAY US MORE.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK IRAQ
SHOULD REPAY THE AMERICAN
TAXPAYER FOR THESE BASES COME UP
FOR WHAT WE HAVE DONE THERE?
SPEAK TO THAT FOR ME.
I SAID, WE BUILT ONE OF THE
WORLD'S MOST EXPENSIVE AIRPORT
FACILITIES ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD.
I WISH WE HAD IT IN NEW YORK.
I WISH WE HAD IT IN WASHINGTON.
WE BUILD RUNWAYS 15,000 FEET
LONG AT LaGUARDIA, 7,000 FEET
LONG.
IN FACT, 20,000 FEET LONG OVER
THERE AND DEEP, THICK CONCRETE
AND STEEL.
NOBODY EVER BUILT RUNWAYS LIKE
THIS, OKAY, WE WERE BUILT BUT
THAT IS OKAY.
BUT WE HAVE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INTO THAT AND I SAID IF YOU
BELIEVE YOU HAVE TO PAY US YOU
HAVE TO PAY US FOR THE MONEY WE
PUT IN.
>> Laura: HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
COLLECT?
WE HAVE A LOT OF THEIR MONEY